samedi si ç'avait été un ami du 72e
groupe scout de cap rouge au québec sont
coincés à l'aéroport de vancouver depuis
hier soir avec art canada et
qui reste place
en guinée débrouillez vous après 11
heures d'attentes pour prendre son vol
vers whitehorse au yukon elle apprend
qu'il est annulé elle et son groupe
n'ont pas le choix que de dormir à même
le plancher de l' aéroport c'est même
pas tout le monde avait son slip en
effet on s'est trouvé sa prime sont
aussi trouvé une guerre vraiment
tranquille comme de l'aéroport qui en
étonne dormi par terre
entre-temps air canada n'a fourni qu'une
allocation de 10 $ pour son déjeuner
et ce n'est que 24 heures plus tard que
la compagnie leur a offert un
hébergement à l'hôtel
et ce genre de déboires à l'aéroport
n'est pas une visiblement que très peu
de voyageurs le cycliste professionnel
guillaume boivin peut en témoigner il a
perdu toute trace de ses bagages à son
arrivée au danemark en vue de sa
participation au tour de france
eric kennedy caroline brunel et leurs
deux enfants ont pris l'avion pour
l'italie le 23 juin ils doivent
maintenant débourser des milliers de
dollars de frais supplémentaires pour
rentrer à la maison
c'est le problème
comme bien d'autres qui recommencent à
voyager sans tessier espère bientôt voir
la lumière au bout du tunnel
ici à briey leproux radio canada
montréal